stephen miller does not support it
he worked in the trump white house for
four years where he worked very hard to
stop this in the un unsuccessfully but
he is still fighting he's the founder of
america first legal he joins us tonight
stephen miller thanks so much
for coming on
so it's hilarious if you think about the
amount of energy they spend shouting at
anyone who notices the numbers the great
replacement theory that's racist
again i would argue race has nothing to
do with this
the numbers tell a very clear story
americans are not replacing themselves
naturally by having children in a
country that's increasingly hostile to
children and immigration is making up
the difference why don't we have a right
to be mad about that
well i think first a bit of history is
an order here
what many americans may not realize is
that during the period of time when the
great american middle class was born
during the eisenhower era when we had
rapid middle class growth rapid increase
in our quality of living rapid increase
in our wages and when immigrant and u.s
born americans alike saw a huge increase
in their living standards there was net
negative immigration into this country
in other words the number of immigrants
leaving was greater than number
immigrants coming every single year to
the point where
we had 14 million immigrants in 1920 by
1965 we had fewer than 10 million
immigrants during that same time period
our population doubled from american
families having kids now since 1965 the
ted kennedy rewrite and joe biden's open
borders
the vast majority of our population
growth is solely people coming here from
foreign countries and as you mentioned
you cannot have social cohesion that way
los angeles is more than one-third
foreign-born new york city is more than
one-third foreign-born san francisco's
more than one-third foreign-born one in
four kids this is amazing in the whole
country one in four kids in the whole
country has a foreign-born parent it is
not in their interests or ours to keep
adding more and more and more and more
immigrants so there can't be any
cohesion there cannot be social trust
there cannot be civic bonding there
cannot be a shared culture a shared
language a shared education a shared
experience and a shared pathway to
success we are eroding and destroying
all of these things by unending
migration
what's so scary is nobody cares about
social cohesion until the crisis hits
and tells the economy tanks and this is
not enough to go around at which point
it becomes the thing that stands between
you and actual chaos are they not
thinking trust is all you have
that's exact situation trust is all you
have if there is an attack and we lose
our power we lose our water we lose our
infrastructure we lose our electricity
what keeps us from riots and looting and
from madness it's trust it's the ability
to know that the people that you are
living in the community with will take
care of each other and protect each
other an uncontrolled migration makes
this a nation of strangers so again i
don't care where you're born no matter
where you're from if you're living here
today it's in your interest to turn off
the spigot tomorrow i think that's a
really smart point and you're seeing a
lot of people
immigrants even arriving in that same
conclusion exactly right stephen miller
great to see you tonight thank you so
much thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight